the measurement axis as you might expect Z measures along the Z axis X along X
and Y along y now remember we're talking about observables because with a Quantum
system we can no longer just know things about the system without measuring them
and each observable has a corresponding operation because measurements require operations it might not be obvious but
it turns out that the operation called operators that correspond to each of these observables x y and z are
rotations of Pi around their respective axes so X is a rotation around X Y
around Y and Z around Z so to see if these operators commute or not we can check to see if rotations
on a sphere commute if they do the uncertainty principle won't apply and we would be able to know X Y and Z about a cubit
with perfect Precision if they don't commute then we'll be able to find a new uncertainty relation for the Cubit watch
the point on this ball as I rotate first around X and then around y it ends up
here now let's try it in the reverse order so I rotate first around Y and
then around X it ends up over here so they definitely don't commute that means
we can't simultaneously know a cubit's exact X Y and Z values will have an
uncertainty relation we'll gloss over the details here but we end up with three different uncertainty
relations so we have Delta x * Delta Y
is greater than or equal to Z Delta y Delta Z is greater than or
equal to X and Delta Z Delta X greater than or equal
to Y so the product of any two of these uncertainties is always greater than or
equal to the expectation value of the third observable let's use kcit to see what
happens when we try to measure both Z and X of the state zero measuring Z is easy it's the so-called standard basis
of the quantum computer measurements are always along Z by default but to measure X we need to perform something called a
basis change basically rotating the Bloss sphere so that X is now pointing up where is z used to point to do this
we use a hadamard gate so the full Quantum circuit will look like this we measure in Z apply the hadamard
and then measure an X if we use the kcit Primitive sampler to run this experiment many times we end
up with a histogram of measurement outcomes that looks like this for the Z
measurement and like this for the measurement in X so as you can see we measured the
Cubit to be in the zero State along Z with pretty close to 100% certainty but
along X we knew basically nothing about the Cubit state it was measured to be either zero or one with equal
probability meaning our UNC C in X was about as big as it can be that gives us
a little sense for this tradeoff of uncertainties but we can do a bit better on our quantum computer we can use a
kcit primitive called estimator to find the expectation values of our observables X Y and Z and the
uncertainty in each let's try it for the state pointing in the plus X Direction on the Block sphere we'll use estimator
to calculate the uncertainties in x and z for this state and the expectation value of
y with this state we get this result from kcit when we take the product of the two
uncertainties in X and Y we see that as expected it's larger than the absolute
value of the expectation value of y but this was just for one particular State we want to make sure this inequality
holds true for all Cubit States so let's use estimator again but this time we'll ask it to scan through the values of a
parameter and to find the expectation values at every single parameter value we give it here the parameter we want to
scan is the angle Theta on the Block sphere so that we check the inequality for all the Cubit states that lie on
this Arc that intersects the XZ plane when we do this we get a plot as a function of the angle Theta the red
curve is the product of the two uncertainties and the orange curve is the expectation value of y as expected
the product of the uncertainties in x and z are much higher than the expectation value of y but that wasn't
too hard to satisfy the inequality because the expectation value of y was so low it was Zero for all the states on
this Arc let's do a similar scan through the Theta values but instead of scanning in the XZ plane we'll set 5 equal to pi/
4 so we're looking at the Cubit states that lie on a different arc on the sphere here we see the inequality is
tested a bit more since the orange curve and the red curve are closer together but the red is always above the orange
and the uncertainty principle still holds we haven't checked all the states yet but hopefully you're starting to get
the idea there's a fundamental unknowability about any two complimentary aspects of a Quantum
System including this Cubit we've been using the uncertainty principle forces us to confront the fact that no matter
how hard we try no matter how clever our measurements are we will never know everything with perfect Precision
there's no getting around it really if you don't believe me or even if you do I challenge you go check out the module
Linked In the description and try to beat the uncertainty principle thanks for watching and I'll see you next time